so let's start out by thinking about
Socrates in bathroom this is where we
left off last class session Nino was
complaining all right
he said Socrates you're like a torpedo
or a stingray people run into you and
they get stunned and they don't know
what to do
and there's actually a Greek term that
gets used a lot in Plato's dialogues
called coria
which which means literally not having a
path not being able to get out of
something so when you're puzzled when
you can't figure out you know what's
what when you're stupefied it's usually
because you thought you knew which way
to go and now the path closes and now
you look around here on the can't go
that way
can't go that way where can I go
sometimes people start to panic with
this happens don't they
particularly if they thought that they
actually kappa paths if they were secure
now we saw last time that Socrates says
well this is actually a good thing it's
not just a bad thing this is a good
thing why is that a good thing when it
comes to thinking about deep topics
yeah so there is this processor at
question is what I actually get psyched
he's killed eventually the Phaedo which
we're gonna read next is the day that he
dies the day of his execution and with
him drinking the poison and the poison
you know going up through his system and
dying people don't like this but if you
actually want to learn things certain
kinds of things certain kinds of deep
topics you have to ask questions it's
not enough just to be supplied answers
how do you know if answers are actually
correct answers you have to question
them you have to subject them to
question interrogation you might say
what else can you say though Socrates
and this why it's not so bad to be
stunned okay yeah it's interesting that
you put a dead bug because usually we
think about in terms of like you've got
some sort of blockage to learning
because you think you know but what
you've got isn't to actually do the real
thing you're putting it into somewhat
deeper way in terms of the whole person
getting to know not just about a thing
getting to know who you are and part
part of who you are what we know so
there's this revealing
situation was respected knowledge so
this Socrates is asking what is virtue
he's asking what is virtue not just
because he doesn't know himself and in
fact he actually doesn't know he's kind
of putting on a show here but in part
because he wants his interlocutor who
thinks that he knows to come to the
point that he realizes no I actually
don't know my answer isn't sufficient I
thought it was and this is taking
something away from some of you right
people don't like that but there are
some things that are better to have
taken away from you right there if you
are sick your doctor gives you
antibiotics they're killing something
though those of you know bacteria that
are making you sick is that a good thing
or a bad thing
how many of you think it's a bad thing
poor bacteria and it's also we have for
that type of bacteria there's a [ __ ]
yeah because it does kill the other good
bacteria in your stomach
generally we sit it's a good thing right
because we don't want to be sick well
the condition that Socrates is trying to
take away is a condition of deterrence
the condition of being stuck in the
realm of mirror false opinion that it's
worse to be thinking that you actually
know and you don't know then they
actually been completely ignorant
you're completely ignorant you at least
can learn right somebody can fill things
in Socrates says that he himself is in
this state of ignorance he himself
doesn't know and you're going to see him
say something similar towards the end
where he's saying I still don't know
what virtue is I'm actually just giving
you an analogy here not necessarily
wisdom or her knowledge so then we don't
bring something up we call this a
parable and it's it's pretty simple if
you don't know something and you want to
find it out how can you do that you
might said wait you're going you know
look it up right google it and then what
we do these days we actually have you
know some some acronyms friend of mine
what I was asking him too many questions
Tommy the one just you know why we're
lucky actually we live in a time where
we can do that Wikipedia is not too bad
some some entries are extra still a lot
but most of them are decent right well
think about something that's happened to
you its students and maybe it's actually
happened to you in this course already
maybe it will happen to or maybe that's
happened in other courses if you really
don't know something do you know where
to start
you're looking for it just a name how do
you know if the information you're
getting is actually correct that's a big
problem with Wikipedia isn't it if
you're not an expert on the subject
you're not quite sure how to evaluate it
and it can get even deeper than that now
imagine there's no Google no Wikipedia
that you're asking about something like
you know what is virtue this is the
nature of moral goodness if you don't
know what it is how are you gonna find
it how would you even know where to go
looking for it and if you already know
it why would you go looking for it
the Meno paradox is leading us to the
sort of conclusion that you know like it
says if you as you know it then you
don't need to look for it if you don't
know when
how will you recognize it when you find
it how would you even know which
direction to go so you know if the Meno
paradox is actually you know a real
reflection of where we are nobody could
really know anything can they amazing
quit college
to be enjoying yourself and you know you
pay a lot of money to enjoy yourself
here so you don't enjoy yourself at home
for a lot cheaper than jail
so clearly this can't actually be the
case and Socrates goes on and he says
you know this is actually just an old
trick that people people like to play on
each other
yeah and says a man cannot try to
discover either when he knows or what he
does not know and the me notions do you
think that's a good argument and
Socrates says no this is what can you
explain to me how it fails if it's not a
good argument then no where is the
problem with this and socrates then what
does he make recourse to so we actually
give him an account right away does he
give does he you know give him a handout
you know a chart or anything like that
what do you remember into doing you is
your remember of course the dialogue
what do you remember happening about
that anybody remember offhand Buddhist
Socrates started talking about that it
almost seems like a real digression well
I mean let me sort of recall it to your
memory starts talking about religion
doesn't he he says I can't explain I've
heard from men and women who understand
the truths of religion you know says
well what did they say and Socrates says
something true I thought and fight
something beautiful
we had some you actually said this stuff
priests and priestesses and
sort of people that make it their
business to account for the function
that they perform and he mentions this
guy pinderhughes Pindar Pindar's a poet
and the poet's a lot of times we're
connected with with Greek religion so he
says well here's what they can say and
here's something that Plato does seem
they actually believe that Socrates does
seem to believe reincarnation
what is this notion of being religious
guys mm-hmm that's exactly a incarnation
is being put into flesh reincarnation
being put it in your clutch so the idea
is that when you die your soul is not
gonna die your body but your body is
just kind of like a hops right yeah that
soul of yours is going to go doing
something we don't we don't know what
there's a lot of difference you know
explanations of this in the different
world religions Plato has his own but
your soul will eventually find its way
to another body you'll be reborn as a
baby and so your soul is already you
know old by that point even though your
body's new what does that mean
going backwards that about your soul
right now if when you die that's going
to happen
exactly so you're you know either
roughly 18 19 20 right the most part you
might be thousands of years old by this
point but a lot of souls
you know bouncing around since there are
some problems with this of course like
you know population is much larger now
so you know we're there whether fewer
souls or souls created in the process
isn't worry about that sort of right put
those sort of problems inside basic idea
is that over and over and over again you
you die and you're born again and
presumably while you were dead something
happened so like he says the soul has
seen all these things that it's looking
for all these things that it wants to
know in a previous life or between the
different fleshly lives and we're going
to talk a bit more about this when we
get to the Phaedo because it gets a
little bit more in-depth about this but
the basic idea is that you as a person
all the things that you actually are
coming to know at least in general
you've seen them that would be the meat
of this so this is leading us towards
this doctrine of recollection there's
one other thing that he says that's that
I think is important to point out that
often gets missed and this is typically
platonic he says that nature or all of
you know the world that we know all of
it is akin or related or connected so if
you understand one part of something you
should be able to understand other
like he says the soul has learned
everything so when a person has recalled
a single bit of knowledge when you've
learned something that you learned
previously there's no reason why it
should not find out all the rest if he
keeps a stout heart if he remains
courageous persevering and does not grow
weary the search for seeking and
learning are nothing but recollection
this is a pretty radical idea yeah this
is something that I tried to get you to
sort of wrap your head around in your
paper so think about when you have
remembered things now things that you
first write you can't actually recall
what you haven't forgotten suppose you
just happen to know it what are some
things that you forgot the last week
that you later on remembered it's
trivial things can be laundry yeah I
make myself to do this and then I don't
put to-do list right out in front
I forget half of stuff
later and like somebody needed to do the
laundry I wonder who that was
now what made you recall to do the
laundry I think I know what the answers
gonna be go ahead I love wash well that
would be yeah there there that or you go
to the drawer and you open up the drawer
and you need a shirt there's no shirts
right now suddenly you recall Oh
somebody was supposed to do the laundry
oh that was me this is a very trivial
example right but that's the process of
recollection
something reminds you some something
else do people remind you of other
people yeah all the time right I mean
you look at people you're like that
person kind of looks like that actors in
that show and now I start thinking about
that show that I haven't thought about
for a while and you start thinking about
the kid the other characters and the
plot today and I want to watch that show
again all these things start going
through your mind it's a rational action
what is to happen
something has to spark it you don't
generally just sort of sit by yourself
and spontaneously remember things do you
something has to recall it to your mind
now here's where we're dealing with a
very interesting idea about flirting
that's somewhat different than what we
have a teacher right and I think sort of
learning
how do we typically think about teaching
away yes someone's telling something
somebody something else and they're the
person is believing them hopefully the
learners like that what you're saying
not a lot of learning is going to take
place does the teacher already have what
it is that they're going to teach the
learner they have to write otherwise
what are they they don't know so the
teacher he has some sort of information
and the process of teaching that is
putting that information however it is
that we do it you know whether we like
cut the tops your heads off pour it in
like alphabet soup or you know run you
through a bunch of exercises that make
you acquire that information or whether
we hand it to you as a paper and say you
know memorize these it's got to somehow
get into the learner and now the learner
has it as a possession so you know what
could go wrong with that there could be
all sorts of good time in some learners
Laura could say I don't believe what
you're saying so you know that done
learning isn't going to take place
learner might not be properly equipped
to take in the information what could go
wrong on the teachers I think about bad
teachers they say again they're not
teaching it
halation yeah maybe they teach it in a
very disorganized fashion and sorry I
said what the students have in a very
disorganized fashion you know I know so
I've heard some stories about you know
teachers who spend more time talking
about personal anecdotes in class than
they do about the actual material what
it's true the students actually learn
about that personal anecdotes about the
material yeah what I'll read even say
when you say that's okay maybe maybe
I'll come back to you there's something
will jog your memory which is really
what this is about
yeah to begin imagination yes the
teacher could themselves be mistaken
about it and then you know teach that
information like for instance you know
one of the counting places in history
class is what did people think about the
world before Christopher Columbus sailed
to America that was WOW now if you
actually know something about history
you know that there were some people who
thought is flat but they were for the
most part ignorant and in the might not
worried that if you read you know people
like already back in the ancient period
they talked about this globe and then if
you read medieval thinkers like Thomas
Aquinas
or handsome they just happened to
mention yeah there was this round as we
all know as we all know so a teacher who
somehow got the idea that you know
everybody thought the world was flat
up until 14 whatever - thanks
they would actually be passing on bad
information I think there's a lot of
teachers who who pass on bad information
that way how would the student know
whether it's good information
information there really wouldn't with
that they were just sort of sucking off
it unless they go in fact unless they
know they need to that check they're not
gonna figure it out
this may be the way that a lot of things
get too hot is this the way everything
gets talking how do you learn things
that are particularly important to you
by doing things I'm are they're getting
the world we're getting them right yeah
there's there's a lot to be learned from
failure sometimes I actually set up
certain exercises in my classes not not
this class but but other classes so that
students will fail most likely and then
we go back and we look at what why did
you fail well I was thinking this I'll
see now you've got to get rid of that
assumption then that's that's you know
sort of achieving something so sometimes
learning is actually taking things away
isn't it and replacing them with other
stuff just the way you learn practical
things I believe you learn the musical
instrument how did you learn the musical
instrument when we say learn the musical
instrument again
what is the flute now how do you play
the flute practice yeah practice
practice practice doing lots of yeah a
repetition scales exercises boring stuff
and then you get to play actual songs
that's a little bit more fun right
then you start to improvise once you've
actually mastered those things that
probably doesn't work the way of just
information getting piled into people's
pets keep that one in mind
another possibility is that students
actually does have the knowledge already
and what does the teacher do all the
teacher does is reminds the student gets
them to recall the information the
knowledge however you want to put it the
understanding that they previously yeah
the more they get more that they do that
and the better the teacher is that the
better the students are learning the
more quickly this will occur so maybe
for some sorts of things I'm not sure
actually that Plato thought that this
would apply to like you know my name is
you know Greg Sadler you just learned
that while you learned that you know
last week I don't think that he thinks
that in a previous life you actually
learned yeah this guy's name is Greg
Sadler but I think that he thinks that
with important things the truths that we
use to structure everything else like
what is the nature of goodness what is
it to be courageous what is justice
really mean that the knowledge is
already in us and all we really need is
a teacher who can successfully bring
these things back to life for us now
it's not an immediate process it takes
you know steps you might say it takes
tries there's a trial and error comes in
with this maybe maybe I should have to
make some mistakes along the way of this
but the knowledge is within us we have
learned this in a previous life
would this get us out of that problem
with the me no paradox
Socrates says it would is he right about
that
about this so if we already know the
things that were supposed to be looking
for we can you know know them in a dim
way you know when it's like when when
you know that there's something that
you're supposed to remember and you just
can't remember what it is
now you've forgotten I need to bring to
mind you guys familiar with that feeling
and sometimes that panic goes along with
that or anxiety or sense of guilt you're
like supposed to do earlier today not
now but earlier today Socrates thinks
that in the governor when you're having
that experience of being stunned being
at a loss than taqueria so he walks this
guy through this geometric proof and I'm
not gonna actually go through the whole
geometric proof what's the point of this
you're showing us something about you
know squares and you know doubling and
quadrupling and all that sort of stuff
why is he doing that well he's trying to
show that that this kid who is a servant
he's had no education at all that this
kid can be led to do the geometry and to
realize geometric truths
if nobody taught that kid that and
Socrates is able to get him to see that
stuff where'd that knowledge come from
yeah I would say like when you
how much the whole shape was yeah both
sides he knew who liked to size what she
did knowledge that's another way of
understanding how we generate new
knowledge we construct that's real like
with building blocks right that didn't
get him everywhere he needed to go I did
it he gets to an ocarina he gets to a
point where each puzzle where he says I
can't figure this out and then Socrates
starts suggesting some things he says
couldn't it be like this and what that
supposed to do is provoke in him
awareness of the knowledge that he
already has how plausible is this - what
do you think yeah well initially the
servant had to have known what his
square is and hadn't known that all the
size of the square our equal subset I
would have had to have told him that
because if he didn't know that he
wouldn't have been able to come up with
all of the things that for all the
responses that behaved to Socrates
so I think initially he would have had
it within taught by somebody and had a
belief what they said about this yeah I
know maybe he figured this out by just
looking at squares and noting things
about them because apparently this guy
is just a service you know and I don't
know a lot of people who sit down with
their servants and extremely squares -
yeah
you know our servants are these things
right all right you know the word robot
actually means it came from check you
know what it means slave this is this is
my my servants it's a good servant to is
I have you know if this thing ever fails
I'm I'm really you know in deep trouble
I don't know anymore phone numbers I use
this your max I use this for all my
emails I hope you probably do as well
we've become alive now you know with
this obviously all that something sort
of hardwired into it you can say that
that thing kind of is like what Socrates
is depicting that the knowledge is
already in it in this case somebody put
it in there so maybe that's not yeah I
find to be problematic with visit like a
teacher only reminds the learning of the
knowledge they have yeah is one that I
mean all people would be sparked by the
same like question to come to the same
conclusion oh okay so that's a good
question if I understand you right
you're saying that the teachers when it
comes to the same issue the same Nanna
that you're supposed to be learning
about the teacher should have some sort
what standard method for bringing the
student to understand that teachers
don't we teach in two different ways
philosophy is a great example they give
us great latitude and these interpret
philosophy classes to teach you guys
some people are going to teach this this
material they're going to teach you
other stuff so they're not teacher play
you at all Plato's not statement that it
has to be like that there could be a lot
of different ways in which the teacher
could evoke the memory and the student
and it might actually require different
kinds of students might require
different kinds of methods in another
dialogue not in this one Socrates talks
about himself as being like a midwife
midwife helps to delivery babies and the
idea is that the baby is already in you
hear in your head and he's just
instrument helping it to come out the
natural processes provided we've got a
midwife there should help the baby
yeah I think you're conclusive right I
mean some of the examples that that
Socrates uses are hard to relate to for
us right shoe makers we don't watch
people making shoes if we hear about
that it's usually headed into sweatshops
yeah it would be kind of funny there but
I was well that's why I was bringing a
bit I was just imagining a teacher who
would like say all right I'm gonna teach
you
here's the standard thing if you don't
learn it this way there's something
wrong with you I've had teachers like
that and luckily I was you know able to
learn it on my own because I got learned
many things from this house you guys
have teachers leagues and I think you
might have the same experience well so
maybe there's some things that this
could work for maybe not everything but
this is definitely Plato's idea about
about teaching and learning so now they
go back to this this this question
Socrates wants to go back to this
question what is virtue right what does
it mean I want to go back to he doesn't
want to go back to that question or say
Socrates like and we need to figure this
out first and the the dialogue takes a
sort of critical turn at this point
exactly
that's a different question Socrates is
you know fairly a medical guy so he says
are you ready to face with me the
question whereas virtue and Meno says
quite right all the same I'd rather
consider the question as I put it at the
beginning and hearing your views I so
notice if Socrates is the teacher he's
actually adapting himself quite a bit to
the student isn't so Meno says I want to
hear your views on on this our way to
pursue virtue as something that can be
talked or the men you have it's a gift
of nature or how does it come about we
know that some people are virtuous we
know that there's something like virtue
out there how does it happen can you can
you actually teach it to somebody so
Socrates says if I were your master as
well as my own me know we should not
have enquired whether or not virtue can
be taught so we first ask what is virtue
because if you want to talk about
whether something can be taught
generally you got to know what it is the
earth you're talking about right and he
says but I'm gonna go along with you
let's listen choir into a single
property of something about whose
essential nature we're still in the dark
so we're going to focus a little bit
more narrowly so Socrates says if we're
going to do this let's think about it
like this what would you have to be the
case for a virtue to be something that
could be taught what is it that can be
taught
what should you be getting provided
within your your classes dad that
involves teaching no teacher should be
on time it should be relatively
interesting to listen to
you know dry dull but those are sort of
besides the point what is the big of
getting out of your classes no technique
yeah yeah for certain for certain things
that's a kind of knowledge technique it
comes from the Greek word actually for
art or skill technique craft knowledge
you know being a musician is it because
of crap but for the most part you're
learning something that you can actually
articulate knowledge in so the question
that we're hosed with death is this is
what most of the rest of the dialogue is
going to be concerned with this is where
Socrates is going to take a lot that
young guy Anytus so if virtue is is
teachable then it has to be knowledge
because knowledge is teachable and they
says virtue is something good we agree
to that right yeah what we want to
figure out so we're going to bring
actually assume that virtue is knowledge
we also know that virtue is a good thing
is there any sort of good thing that's
not knowledge
it says if there exists any good thing
different from a not associated with
knowledge virtue could be that
all things so useless let's think about
the list of good things what are some
things that we consider good he brings
up good this is the by the way this is
one of the passages that later on when I
show you what a close reading is I'm
going to bring together with some other
passages so health right it's health a
good thing anybody here want to be sick
prefer to be sick you rather be healthy
just got home is more of it yeah you
know you could be a maximal point I
guess but most of us would like to be
healthier strength anyone want to be
weaker than you are currently you like
being strong good looks
anybody want to be bad looking I look
worse than you currently do the that's
ahead of you you know you know if you
don't watch it when you get older right
some things are gonna happen that you
don't have much control over you know
some of you guys some of you women hair
is gonna start to fall out you know not
gonna whoops if the mind is still mostly
here what you can do about that right
why does it bother you if it does happen
because good folks are a good thing
right
wealth is wealth a good thing anybody
here one I have less money than you
currently they won't hear one of you
before say here I mean you're already if
you didn't do anything after Marist
you'd already be well on the way when
Judith is going to wearing a Maris
posture could been money some of you may
be anything death because of that I
don't think you're going into debt
because you want to be in debt if you're
a student
I think you're going into death because
you think you'll make more money later
on right so these are all good things
can they be bad things and they be
turned to harm sometimes let's think
about good lucks can somebody's good
looks never be a problem for them yeah
how awesome is arguably be giving them a
tip a target that's interesting yeah I
suppose what were you saying
yeah think about people who get by on
their looks life what does that do to
their character I think you may have
known some people already you know 20
years 18 19 years that you guys have
been around I've seen some people who
just got by on good looks how things
turn out what else does it do to your
character though I mean you know we've
got that old joke about
very personalities ooh all of them and
well you know turns out great
personalities a bit more constant and a
bit more important that necessarily
stellar looks perfectly symmetrical
cheekbones or something like that right
get into well convulse carita you ever
be able to look into what happens to
people who win the lottery
everyone says nah man I just won the
lottery I do this and then I'm so happy
because everything have you taken care
of it be on easy street is that what
really happens well we could use one
like millions of dollars
well I would actually do loses their
money over time a lot of them don't turn
out to be very happy if it breaks up the
marriages they're lined up kind of
bitter how does that happen
I mean well this is a good thing isn't
it so how can a good thing be 15 and he
goes on a little bit more and he says
let's think about mental or spiritual or
something you know psychological
personality characteristics like
temperance the capacity to keep yourself
within certain limits justice courage
quickness of mind memory those sorts of
things those always good well let's take
courage for example courage is a good
thing isn't it
no general any of you wanna be cowards
you like people who are cowards who you
know back away from anything that's
difficult troubling when you need a
minute you think about your friends you
want your friends to be courageous where
would you prefer your friends to be
like diverse as we nowadays say rather
than common people cowards
the oppressive because somebody say yes
why why does it matter to you yeah for
once a difficulty arises still actually
confronted yeah I mean isn't somebody
else is talking about you behind your
back you want your friend actually stand
up for you and not say oh I don't know
if I should say anything to get into you
know a rough situation with somebody you
want them to literally have your back so
that nobody gets behind you and and
knocks your outer stabs you in the back
you want friends to actually stand up to
toughness adversity than these sorts of
things because converters we're never
going to sell you out somebody who
actually doesn't stand up for some all
things that's gonna stand out for big
things you don't actually want people
like that reasons so courage is a good
thing
are there new age' courage can be bad I
can go somewhere you might say you know
any people who are like like Socrates
says courage can also sort of degenerate
into something like a sort of you know
thoughtless confidence do you know any
people like that there are any examples
of
I think you would probably know a lot do
you know any people who like to get in
fights either verbal or physical for no
good reason just to just to do it yes
you'd say that they're courageous but
they're not really courageous they just
have a kind of crazy confidence
I know exactly like you know that's
that's something claim to practice
martial arts was to go and get in bar
fights I was younger than you guys I was
still in high school it was working in a
restaurant with this guy and I was
practicing karate at the time and you
know spending a lot of time yeah and he
said yeah I knew Tai Chi you a learner
that's all that sounds great
it's always nice to compare different
you know different styles with each
other okay meet me in this bar you know
this day I was like no bar are we gonna
practice there is law going I that fight
with people that's how I practice it I
don't know that's that was that kind of
guy do you know people who are too
aggressive in argument with other people
many friends like that family members
that's courage doing that so what what's
required in order to actually make these
good things good things reliable yeah
community oh yeah
Plato doesn't talk about that now that
would be a very sort of stoic or a
Christian answer
which is gonna come in later on the
Greeks didn't know much at least in
Plato and Aristotle sign about humility
they tended to see it is not a
particularly good thing but we do right
Plato has a different answer what is the
thing that you need in order to make
good things remain reliably to this
wisdom the wisdom to actually use those
things well if you won the lottery it
doesn't mean your life has to go go to
hell
what would a smart person who won the
lottery do what's earth yeah
yeah it would save the Balkan first day
they pay out like I think like close to
45 percent of the federal government no
no yeah as far as I understand it was
just kind of a ripoff but probably the
state wants to take a little late to
write certainly our statement but then
yeah and you better bank most of them
actual outs you know change your
lifestyle or radically probably to get
an intrusive incremental changes instead
of buying yourself a five million dollar
mansion you know ten thousand square
feet if you're used to living in a 1,000
square feet place and you go to a 10,000
square foot place you wouldn't know what
to do with yourself you doesn't wander
around aimlessly would you would you
guys stay in school here at Marist if
you how many of you by show of hands how
many people in what because you'd go
somewhere else already just retired at
age 19 20 find something else
interesting to do
yeah what do you think about do going
back school later okay
those of you that stay here at
management I would just stay here
embarrasses I mean you wouldn't be
because you're you need this school to
get a good job right you're already
taking care of your life why would you
stay here
I'm sure there's if you have that sort
of money though I mean think about the
fun you can have just like we have
hyperinflation money is no longer worth
anything imagine that's not the case
yeah that's something you could actually
ask yourself to another in class it's
even in this class the ask yourself is
the knowledge that you're actually
learning is this something that you're
gonna care about ten years from now or
not because I would guess some of the
answer is yes and some will be no it
could be that there's some things that
you want that you didn't realize you so
knowledge is a good and knowledge is for
Plato the good which is going to allow
you to make good use of these these
other goods it's what is great to make a
person virtuous so he says if then
virtue is an attribute of the Spirit and
for the soul the psyche and one which
can't fail to be beneficial
it must be wisdom it must be the
capacity to judge things correctly to
figure things out to use things the way
they want to be used if we accept this
argument that virtue must be attended
wisdom or a kind of knowledge so what
does this mean that I says the right
user the right user of these good things
is the mind of the wise man wrong you
foolish person there's an opposite to
his following or foolishness so he says
then if this is if this is so then good
men can are good people cannot be fitted
by nature there's also some science
fiction stories with babies no no too
much what's your experience little
babies actually with little kids pretty
dumb aren't they you know if you
actually how many of babysat before like
toddlers kids are great at like getting
into stuff that they're not supposed to
get into and getting themselves hurt and
so a lot of what you have to do is I
keep them from using things to hurt
themselves father's job is to keep the
daughter Paul but he also know it's
Louise Louise the kid he says basically
as a parent when you've got small kids
your job is just to keep them from
killing themselves and if you do that
you're doing okay why because they're
foolish because they have no idea how to
use things so that's the case we don't
stand out virtuous how do we become
virtuous well we have to acquire wisdom
or or knowledge and if that's the case
then somebody should be able to teach it
right it's a virtue is a kind of
knowledge or wisdom so now we get to
another another another topic this is
this question about teachers and
students together and he's framing it in
terms of his own society and mainly in
terms of like political acumen and being
at what he calls the Statesman you know
so think about people like you know the
secretary of state or the president
authority and Senator it's people who
run things but we have a lot more
running of things and they and we have
corporations he had colleges and
educational institutions those sorts of
things the idea that he has is there are
some people are particularly good at
that they do a great job thing they
benefit their community right and we
could look at like you know for instance
you had to pick in the last hundred
years somebody was a political leader
who you think on hold on hold on average
they did a really good job and they left
the country better off than they they
got would you think they pick anybody
are they off they're all a bunch of
crooks yeah
okay yeah I mean you inherited a country
that would actually like had a
depression going up the whole world was
in a massive wolf you know crisis and
some parts even you know way worse than
it was for us and a lot of the
democracies in the world call the
fascism from the National Socialism for
militarism
we had enemies you know stockpiling arms
and getting ready to wipe out the
democracies that existed and he got the
nation's through that created a lot of
stuff in the process you know as legacy
is somewhat uneven the way it always is
but on the whole I think it did a pretty
good job so you could be somebody that
played over to have a virtue did FDR
Castaneda
can you teach anybody else copy Richard
maybe no Socrates asks this young guy
Kansas and he's part of the political
elite in the affluent success so virtue
is a kind of knowledge who's teaching it
this is a real question to ask yourself
we'll think about it the way that he
does that first if you want to teach
somebody something if you want them to
learn something let's say you have some
kids now where do you set up
school and what should be happening at
events teacher should be setting a good
example for what they're trying to teach
their students yeah teachers probably
also have to know what their they're
teaching here right so now if you want
them somebody learning academic subjects
like mathematics yeah sometimes to
school you want to do so many music most
places do you actually want to learn how
to play an instrument how the same -
yeah - somebody who can teach them and
why did that person teach them that they
actually does you want guitar lessons
don't take it from the guy who knows how
to play the trombone take it from the
guy who knows how to play guitar right
if you want to be a gardener you can
take Master Gardener classes what do you
think is teaching the classes Master
Gardeners if you want to go to culinary
school right up the road do you know who
I mean there's there's lots of other
things that they study they have liberal
arts and business management and all
that but the real core of the culinary
is baking and pastry which is on a
smaller and culinary arts and all those
people in baking and pastry in culinary
arts those are all shops and most of
them are actually CIA grads
they're from that same school because
that's a top culinary school in the
world
right down the road so presumably a chef
shouldn't know how to make another chef
shouldn't feel semantic knowledge
whatwhat about hurt you oral goodness
shouldn't that work the same way who do
people send their kids to to learn about
how to be a good person overall not just
a good musician or a good chef but any
actual good person somebody who can run
the ER their their life well and that
screw it up well in ancient Athens I
want you to think about how we did this
in our office
Tippett in ancient Athens there were a
couple different choices one was
hopefully you'd learned it from your
parents or maybe they'd send you to
somebody else somebody else in the upper
class who seemed to have it together or
they would send you to a professional
teacher the Sophists and the Sophists
claimed to be able to teach people this
sort of thing
anta says no they actually can't and
Plato's attitude is they they can't
either the reason they can't is they're
not particularly good guys themselves
and they don't seem to know a lot about
this when you push them what about
sending them to you know just plain old
good people are those people good at
making other people into good people
yeah but if they could they would the
same thing happens in our society isn't
it don't don't you know some people who
have good parents and you look at the
kids you're like wow they're awful
now there's other people who have awful
parents and you know you really feel bad
for them maybe some of your friends and
you actually think this friend is a good
person there doesn't seem to be a
correlation there and this is something
I'm not going to we're not to explore
here but I want you to think about who
do you go to to learn in our society
about how to be a good person
the last thing that I want to hit on
before we get to this so these people in
Plato's times some of them were in fact
people they couldn't make their children
good people why not well it's because
they didn't have knowledge so if they
didn't have knowledge what did they have
this is a very important photonic
metaphor of trying to get from point A
to point B if you need to get from here
let's pick something nearby you need to
get from from here to there new balls
what's one of the things that you have
to do you got across the river somehow
there's only so many places you can do
that and I would say all actually do
possess in fact knowledge about how to
get to here new faults now you might
just sort of like happen on that buy
happy gas or something like that and
he's a hi there must be a river around
here somewhere I think there you know I
guess I had to find a bridge just sort
of muddle through that's what a lot of
people who are successful in running
their lives or in running organizations
actually do they don't actually know
what they're doing they don't have
knowledge because they're not able to
explain what it is that they're doing
adequately that can give you some sort
of explanations but their explanations
break down and as soon as you start
pulling on the strings they unravel they
also they can't teach other people they
can't make other people virtuous in that
way they are able to get by they are
able to hit the mark that's because they
just happen to have the right opinion on
things I think this is something that
would apply equally to our own society
the person has the right opinion
probably not going to get things right
all the time there's gonna be some cases
where they screw up a great example of
this I would say is in business how many
very business majors you're thinking
about going into business okay one of
those sort of things that they tell you
this business models change every five
years you guys for that yeah okay do we
know that that's actually true it might
not actually be true B we'd have to like
look at the facts and see whether that's
actually the case well let's assume that
that
the case what a business models change
everything because the best that they
could possibly be is happening to get it
right for a while not having full
knowledge about things just happening to
get it right for a while there are
people who run their lives like this
these are all familiar with the term
midlife crisis right people get into
midlife crises in part from a plutonic
perspective because they've run their
life satisfactorily up until this point
and then suddenly things start to go off
and haywire and they don't actually have
knowledge about what's good and bad
what's right he actually never does
solved question what is virtue doesn't
in this dialogue done with a lot of
other things we've cleared a lot of
space but we haven't actually gotten to
what is virtue itself and Socrates is
kind of sad about this after the end it
says you know where are these people
getting virtue from maybe the divine
dispensation maybe the gods give it to
him who knows where it comes from and he
says we'll have to you know talk about
this some other time
maybe down the line we can actually
figure out so the asking how do people
get virtue
try to figure out what virtue actually
is you sidetrack me me know we didn't
get to where we wanted we did accomplish
a few things along the way but they're
mostly taking away errors sort of taking
away opinions that people think are
right we haven't actually gotten to
knowledge about it so here's something
sort of you know leave what to think
about is that a bad thing is that a
disappointment
there's something more going on in this
text than just what's on the surface
that's what that smell leave you with
and have a good weekend